hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play in space too okay we're in
some sort of a garbage room and I have
to shut it down alright sorry buddy
prep school pile up oh okay Oh safe
dinner the chamber oh [ __ ] oh come on no
today out what the hell
shouldn't have pulled off all the blades
off that other one yeah nope gum ah now
you know nothing it nope you don't even
have your explody anymore
are you even a little bit oh there's
your right anyone else
I'll sure use this before boom gimme
your goodies come here
oh okay and that's it how much ammo
again probably not enough ah a decent
amount I'll keep using the plasma cutter
and hopefully as a go by I'll pick up
more of the ammo for the other guns
hello baby buddy home launch and land
press alt' okay Oh
oh this is much better I thought it was
just going to launch me across the room
like this this is awesome
I'm flying well I may get disoriented
just as quickly
oh hello item is it different from agon
Oh God
objectively is it garbage okay I'll get
you there I'm gonna find out where this
goes I'll get back down oh yeah
yep damn that is awesome man this game
is impressive really like this nope
don't trust you
uber no glad I came in here and goodies
okay and then through that room anywhere
goodies just floating around probably
car everywhere I guess a space station
would use pointed up nope not today okay
Ksenia Park
okay seems like a really weird place to
go wherever I need to go
and I did what now
love the way
pointy join
sukkah
well Justin
okay
oh that's heavy
don't go into the plan
oh no all right here
yep breaking Wow I like this I like this
a lot
yeah camera you hear the Gus
Oh Oh God
it is dark I know a lot of guys have
been saying that it's really dark it is
really dark it's darker than it was in
Dead Space 1 and this is especially
I'm gonna jump out at me you ah I knew
it I knew it
give me that here yours anymore
okay o karna pogrom ah those ayianna the
ruby ruby Simkin right bronze extremely
rare electronic component bronze doesn't
sound as good as gold or Ruby
it looks purple pink purple pink well
that was very worth it by the worst yeah
yeah I got it
karma what is there anything else here
was so dark I didn't see
I hear what sound like monster but I've
been here in months
okay nothing here okay nevermind I'm
dumb
I am dumb moving on
Oh
I'm surprised they got just as many
elevators as they did in the last man
except the world that it will be looks
exactly like the one they had in the
other game no power note yeah can't see
a bloody thing yeah it looks good last
time I saw candles people were going
crazy so don't mind me while I don't
trust you I guess I'm to throw a yeah I
know a Necromorph ahem
ha ha got ya ha ha at it that really it
all aah aah Oh No hey those things I
probably should have thrown something at
it I just wasted like for bowling
OOP Dex like more reading mm-hmm from
Sally Henin to Marian Henin Marian I'm
just going to leave this log here for
you to find when you come get the rest
of my stuff I hope I don't forget
anything this is a really big deal the
rebirth is going to happen very very
soon just like I they said this is a
very special time like once in a
lifetime actually once in a million
lifetimes they say we've been preparing
for this since before we were human do
you know how special that makes us we're
the ones who get to see it I'm so
excited my skin is tingling with
monsters I've got chills of monsters
okay I've gotta go the ceremonies begin
in half an hour
for the monsters I don't want to be late
buzzers I love you so so much
come join us ha ha ok bye Sally Oh Sally
what you're probably dead he's probably
got monsters in you
that that Altman that the Altman I've
heard so much about ha no not more take
that and that and that oh wow did you
see me go ah have an arm can't get
something else that's ro have a head ah
ha joy shrine yeah
ponies with you it's a Pony Express yeah
yeah so guys what it is do not like
those little guys guess you think uh
toilet even little details like that
like an automatically flushing toilet
little details Laura I'm else
I'm said oh oh don't trust you
what do you have a thing on your head
did you kill yourself ooh creepy
little miniature marker why did they
know about the marker I thought the
marker was a secret thing but everyone
seems to know about it
whoa oh yeah
okay Isaac started to get some sense no
she's not
you're not crazy man totally not crazy
the marker will save us yeah it's done a
good job so far
y'all look pretty darn saved look little
details love the little details love it
what's what's go through hang on why go
through there I gotta explore who knows
what goodies I would find wait a minute
wasn't I just here up there I really
went all that way to do skit oh good kid
stasis pack okay whatever that don't
matter I could have jumped down and been
fine ah here we go
you see what you got is store for me
Oh data tiny soldiers have found me
attractive myself sorting gunship form
uh yeah hurry
yeah still don't trust you they're not
even shooting it like a well they
probably I want to break the windows
probably no grab no air out there
whatever they really want to give hi hey
I'm trying to loot here is that she try
to lose them
Yemen yeah don't go get me ha huh don't
behind me wham-bam seem to be anything
else up here and down I go
alright huh Oh what the hell
what is that sorry big you honestly any
game I play from now on I'm always gonna
play it on the hardest difficulty that's
available to be in the beginning because
this is just so much more fun I can
actually die which makes it a bit more
thrilling
I don't but from now on like every game
I play I'm gonna do it axle art because
I am a halfway decent gamer I can take
it and I like the challenge and it's
probably more impressive for you guys if
I do it a little tougher I mean there's
stories great no but I'll get through
the game I'm that good what what what
what I know you don't I know you
I cut your cord but oh you got got your
head what you gonna do now and get puke
on me I'll put that up wat boom this
I'm fine you're not gonna go down here
to get hit with that [ __ ] ah I thought I
blocked that with my chair fine
I'm slow down really ah what happened
what was there an exploding guy behind
me okay never mind
but I think I said I'm gonna play every
game from now on on super easy ah okay
never mind
well I just embarrassed myself let me do
a little strategy whoo I got lots of
ammo for these
oh god the screwed up positioning on
this thing's just amazing so I'm gonna
can I plant these on walls booyah oh no
you know what nothing's gonna get behind
me this time ha ha Oh got you all that
blue balls of oh damn it
gonna getcha got you nope Oh faster hey
not bad
you let him go oh hi why aren't you done
okay how's that knows that where's the
exploding guy javelin Spears that one's
not detonated but I can retrieve it
I really should use these more strategic
aha
got ya good well here they come
you're not gonna live ah that's where
you can get done
I said get God ah what it was new Oh
kidding me ah yeah ah be kidding me
alright whatever I can deal I just need
to place these a bit more strategic
there Oh what the hell that didn't kill
you you son of a [ __ ] I'm in it I swear
I swear I'm gonna aah
no not today none of it II you Hey I
mean I am eating I Plast II many many
times
no not today not today
Donna mood ah that wasn't what I was
trying to grab but whatever oh oh you're
all going down now
Oh with that huh okay I'll miss oh not
with this one though all right all right
okay that all done done now can't see a
bloody thing just make sure I clean up
all the bodies for all the goodies yeah
I project I brought I brought that on
myself like I feel like I'm so good I
can handle the Hard difficulty oh I died
ah I got again oh I'm such a loser but I
can't believe the grenade launcher
didn't do anything to that guy are they
dead near maybe was not really a grenade
launcher Alan but either way that's all
the time I got for this part thank you
guys so much for watching hope you're
enjoying it so far
now see you in the next part bye bye